bonsoir merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france on a vu ce couple tout de
même inquiet dans quel état d'esprit
êtes vous l'état d'esprit de l'ensemble
de la filière viticole en tv est
évidemment a décrit plutôt atteindre 13
antennes depuis le début de l'épidémie
après sans que beaucoup de régions
viticoles était en grande difficulté
avant le commis de 2,9 des problèmes de
marché liée au ralentissement de la
chine lié à des taxes plus faible pour
une concurrence le marché chinois est
ensuite aussi des taxes des américains
liées au contentieux entre airbus et
boeing ont mis la filière viticole
française en grande difficulté depuis le
convient de 10,9 c'est bien pire puisque
votre reportage va bien précise et une
grande partie de nos marchés le marché
de traditionnels de la restauration des
dents aux particuliers est fortement
impacté les baisse de 90% comme
l'exemple manadiers précédemment sont
assez réguliers dans beaucoup
d'entreprises viticoles françaises
donc c'est un arrêt brutal de la
commercialisation de la viticulture et
devait affronter
est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir une
compensation notamment via le secteur de
la grande distribution on imagine que
les français apprécient le bon vin chez
eux en cette période de confinement est
ce que vous sentez à mieux de ce point
de vue là difficile à mesurer
c'est très difficile à mesurer il ya
bien sûr les apéros réguliers qui peut y
avoir entre entre amis mais nous avons
aujourd'hui davantage de de consolation
issus ou d'achat de la grande
distribution
nous avons aussi l'affaiblissement de la
consommation de vin nous mesurons
aujourd'hui à partir de cette première
quinzaine d'avril le mois de mars a été
plutôt positif à la grande distribution
mais la consommation aujourd'hui
à domicile est plutôt en baisse est
plutôt sur des m2 d'entrée de gamme on
sent que les français n'ont pas n'ont
pas le coeur à investir dans des déserts
plus haut de gamme aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous vous sentez vous sentez
soutenue par le gouvernement
il ya 82 mesures qui ont été prises
rapidement notamment pour le chômage
partiel bien sûr la possibilité à notre
secteur de pouvoir continuer à
travailler
c'est évidemment une crainte que nous
avions bien début de l'agriculture fait
partie des secteurs prioritaires la
viticulture
on peut penser que ça ne pourrait pas
être acceptées en prioritaire mais
l'arrêt du travail dans les vignes et
pendant deux mois
viens de ralentir le travail d'une année
complète les d'une récolte complète donc
nous pouvons continuer à travailler ça
c'est une bonne chose
le chômage partiel est une bonne chose
mais nous avons besoin d'outils bien
dont ceux bien plus importants notamment
de la souplesse sur les outils européens
qui sont à notre disposition et ensuite
nous aurons besoin de financement pour
relancer la mécanique relancer la
machine et faire la promotion sur des
grands marchés est aussi outrés de nos
consommateurs
c'est globalement pardonnez-moi certains
préconisent la distillation de crise
comme l'eurodéputé du sud-ouest un eric
andrieu c'est quelque chose qui serait
de nature à vous soulagé oui j'allais y
venir c'est c'est le sujet que je
voulais aborder la destination sera un
outil indispensable pour venir alléger
le stock tous les invendus pendant plus
de deux mois d'une année et bowling
considérable il va falloir danger la
récolte sera sans doute diminué parce
que nous serons sans doute très modérée
sur sur la récolte et sur les volumes
récoltés cette année pour autant un
volume et un stock important sur un
stock de vin bien pénalisé les marchés
bien alourdir ce marché vient détruire
l'économie du marché pendant de longs
mois
lorsque l'on constate ces stocks
importants donc il faut aller chez ses
stocks et la distillation de crise est
le meilleur outil à court terme mais
ensuite il faudra évidemment relancer
les
viticole relancer le marché dit d'un il
faudra aussi trouver les moyens de
sortir des taxes et aujourd'hui avec des
états unis trouver des moyens aussi
d'avoir une meilleure compétitivité sur
certains marchés là aussi il ya des
taxes plus importante pour les européens
je pense notamment à la chine merci
beaucoup bernard farges est président du
conseil interprofessionnel du vin de
bordeaux d'avoir été avec nous